well congrats on your new song man i  love on the ground it is such a cool  song  um how would you describe your new music  to everyone  i would say this song really resonates  with  me myself uh there's a part in the song  that says i've worked my whole life  just to get high just to be like look at  me i'm never coming down  but um it eventually says but everything  i need is on the ground and this is just  it's just a song that kind of tries to  keep everybody grounded  yeah tell everybody take a moment to sit  back and think about what really matters  you know to us absolutely it's also one  hell of a vibe  it's a really cool song i'm into it want  more fun stuff  i thought so check out these videos  floating around my head  this one is really cool i'm just saying  no pressure